From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. So one of the people who works on our radio show, her brother was going through a rough time. And he called their mom, kind of panicking. And the mom was like, you know, you just need to stop thinking about this stuff. And he was like, Mom, that is not possible.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们广播节目的一个工作人员，她的兄弟当时正处于一段艰难时期。他打电话给妈妈，有些惊慌失措。妈妈对他说，你知道，你只需要停止去想这些事情就行了。他说，妈，那是不可能的。
And she was like, that is totally possible. What you have to do is you have to take the bad thought and put it into a box in your head. Then, you have to take the box out of your head, and put it in a cupboard, and shut the cupboard.
她说，这完全是可能的。你需要做的是，把坏念头放进脑海里的一个盒子里。然后，你得把那个盒子从脑子里拿出来，放进柜子里，关上柜门。
I love the completeness of that. It's like the box in the head was not enough, right? That image maybe worked for their mom when she was young. But then she was like, I have not extinguished the bad thoughts quite enough. I need more. I need a cupboard. Next time our producer and her brother were visiting her parents, she told me, the two of them were all just like, "don't open the cupboards!"
我喜欢这种彻底感。就好像光有脑子里的盒子还不够，对吧？那个意象在妈妈年轻时可能管用。但后来她又觉得，我还没能完全消除那些坏念头。我需要更多，我需要一个柜子。下一次我们的制作人和她兄弟去看望父母时，她告诉我，他们两人当时的心态就像是，“千万别打开那些柜子！”
Denial usually gets a bad rap. Compartmentalizing your feelings, keeping it all inside, pretending things never happened-- these are not signs of psychological health. What they're signs of is adulthood. If you do those things, basically, you're an adult because being an adult means sucking it up, getting on with it, going to work even if you have a cold because you're an adult. You do your job.
否认通常名声不好。把情绪隔绝起来，憋在心里，假装事情从未发生——这些并不是心理健康的标志。它们是成年人的标志。如果你做了这些，基本上，你就是一个成年人，因为成年意味着忍气吞声，继续生活，哪怕感冒了也要去上班，因为你是成年人。你得做好你的工作。
I'm not complaining. In fact, today's entire show is a defense of not thinking about it, of not knowing-- a defense, in short, of ignorance. We have three very different stories. You can decide how convincing they are. Stay with us.
我并不是在抱怨。事实上，今天的整个节目就是为“不去想它”、“不去了解”进行辩护——简而言之，为“无知”进行辩护。我们有三个截然不同的故事，你可以决定它们有多大的说服力。请继续收听。
Act One, What You Don't Know. Lulu Wang has this case study of people not admitting the truth.
第一幕，你所不知道的事。露露·王讲述了一个人们不愿承认真相的案例。
When my grandmother was diagnosed with stage 4 lung cancer, she was given three months to live. She was 80 years old, and my family, for reasons I'll get into in a minute, decided not to tell her. I was totally against this.
当我祖母被诊断出患有肺癌晚期时，医生说她只剩下三个月的生命。她当时80岁，出于稍后我会提到的原因，我们全家决定不告诉她。我完全反对这样做。
When I heard the news, I wanted to talk with my grandmother, comfort her. I wanted to grieve with her in the way that seems natural when someone you love is dying. But my mom-- she's the one who called me to give me the bad news-- quickly informed me that what I wanted, that what I thought was the right thing to do, would not be permitted and that I would have no say in the matter. I was stunned.
听到这个消息时，我想和祖母谈谈，安慰她。我想以一种在爱人垂死时显得自然的方式与她一起哀悼。但我的母亲——是她打电话告诉我这个坏消息的——迅速通知我，我想要的东西，我自认为正确的事，是不被允许的，而且在这件事上我没有发言权。我惊呆了。
My grandmother, or Nainai, as I call her, lives in China, along with a lot of my other relatives. My parents and I live here in the United States. I'm really close to my Nainai. At 2 years old, I lived with her and my grandfather for a year so my mom could work. Nainai is 5 foot tall with a full head of permed, white hair. She's small, but when my Nainai walks into a room, everyone listens.
我的祖母，或者我叫她“奶奶”，和我的许多其他亲戚住在中国。我的父母和我住在美国。我和奶奶非常亲。我两岁时，曾和她以及爷爷住了一年，好让妈妈去工作。奶奶身高五英尺，满头烫过的白发。她个子很小，但每当她走进一个房间，每个人都会听她说话。
I wasn't the only one who felt weird keeping this a secret. My dad thought about going to his mom and telling her she was dying.
并不是只有我一个人觉得保守这个秘密很奇怪。我爸爸曾想过回去告诉他妈妈她快不行了。
But then what? I could not take care of her because I have my own family back in the United States, right? I have my job here. And then I won't be able to take the responsibility of being with my mom.
但之后呢？我没法照顾她，因为我在美国有自己的家庭，对吧？我在这儿有工作。而且，我将无法承担陪伴在母亲身边的责任。
It's true. My dad wasn't the one on the ground looking after Nainai. He left China when he was just a teenager. His older brother has lived in Japan for 24 years. The person who was on the ground was Nainai's younger sister.
确实如此。我爸并不是在当地照顾奶奶的那个人。他十几岁就离开了中国。他的哥哥在日本已经住了24年。在当地照顾奶奶的人是奶奶的妹妹。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
This is her, my Nainai's sister, my great aunt. She looks almost identical to Nainai. In Chinese, I call her [CHINESE], which translates to Little Aunt Grandma. But I'll just call her Little Nainai for this story.
这就是她，我奶奶的妹妹，也就是我的姨奶奶。她看起来和奶奶几乎一模一样。在中文里，我叫她“姨奶奶”。
Little Nainai lives in the apartment right upstairs from Nainai, and they're very close. She was the one who picked up the results of Nainai's physical. It's customary in China for doctors to give bad news to family members rather than giving it directly to the patient, especially if the patient is older. Nainai's doctor recommended that Nainai be immediately hospitalized for treatment.
姨奶奶住在奶奶楼上的公寓里，她们关系非常亲密。是她去拿了奶奶的体检报告。在中国，医生通常把坏消息告诉家属，而不是直接告诉病人，特别是如果病人年纪较大。奶奶的医生建议立即住院治疗。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
She's saying the doctor told her the cancer was very advanced. To not hospitalize her would be irresponsible. Of course, in order to hospitalize Nainai, it means they'd actually have to tell her she's sick.
她说医生告诉她癌症已经非常严重了。不让她住院是不负责任的。当然，为了让奶奶住院，就意味着他们必须得告诉她她生病了。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
Little Nainai told the doctor that Nainai is too old, that she couldn't handle a blow like this. It's not just that Little Nainai didn't want to upset her sister with the news of her death. She actually believed that not telling her was a way to prolong her life. Knowing Nainai's personality, Little Nainai worried that her sister would get overwhelmed with fear and depression. She'd stop eating. She'd stop sleeping. She'd lose interest in life. The Chinese believe that mental and emotional health are completely linked to physical health.
姨奶奶告诉医生奶奶年纪太大了，承受不了这样的打击。不仅仅是因为姨奶奶不想用死讯打扰她的姐姐。她真心相信，不告诉她是延长她寿命的一种方式。了解奶奶的性格，姨奶奶担心她会被恐惧和抑郁压垮。她会停止进食，停止睡眠，对生活失去兴趣。中国人认为心理和情感健康与身体健康是完全挂钩的。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
She tells me there's a Chinese joke. Two people go get a physical. One of them is healthy, and one of them has a terminal illness. The hospital gets the results mixed up. The healthy person gets a terminal prognosis and vice versa.
她告诉我一个中国的笑话。两个人去体检。一个是健康的，一个是绝症的。医院把结果搞混了。健康的人得到了绝症诊断，反之亦然。
So then the healthy person ends up dying while the sick person ends up living.
结果，那个健康的人最终死了，而那个生病的人却活了下来。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
That's me asking Little Nainai, is that really a joke? It's not very funny.
那是我在问姨奶奶，那真的是个笑话吗？一点也不好笑。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
She assured me that it was. My family got a second opinion, and then a third. Same prognosis-- three months, maybe less. Little Nainai knew she needed a fake medical report to show Nainai, so she went to a print shop. They told her, we can't create a false medical record. If you want to make something up, we could photocopy it for you. Little Nainai whited out the real diagnosis and wrote down words that sounded vaguely medical but unalarming, something about the nine shadows.
她向我保证那就是个笑话。我家人去寻求了第二次、第三次意见。诊断结果一样——三个月，甚至更短。姨奶奶知道她需要一份假的医疗报告给奶奶看，于是她去了打印店。店员说，我们不能伪造病历。如果你想编造什么，我们可以帮你复印。姨奶奶把真实的诊断结果涂掉，写上了一些听起来模糊但并不吓人的词，类似于“九种阴影”之类的东西。
My family built on that lie with an even more elaborate one. We realized we had a problem. How are we all going to manage to see Nainai before she died? Family from three countries needed to say goodbye without letting Nainai know we were actually saying goodbye. This would require more than Wite-Out. My dad had an idea.
我家人用一个更精心的谎言来支撑那个谎言。我们意识到遇到了一个问题。我们怎么才能在奶奶去世前设法见她一面呢？来自三个国家的亲戚需要道别，还不能让奶奶知道我们实际上是在道别。这需要的不仅仅是涂改液。我爸有个主意。
So I said, all right, your uncle, maybe we can just, you know, stage your son's wedding early, one year early.
所以我说，好吧，叔叔，也许我们可以提前举行你儿子的婚礼，提前一年。
Are you proud that you came up with this idea?
你为自己想出这个主意感到自豪吗？
Well, you know, I'm the-- everybody considered me as the smartest in the family. So I mean, it's a show. I mean--
嗯，你知道，我是——大家都认为我是家里最聪明的。所以我的意思是，这就像是一场戏。我的意思是——
This was our plan-- a giant goodbye party disguised as a giant wedding banquet.
这就是我们的计划——一场伪装成盛大婚礼宴会的巨大告别派对。
This is the lie that everybody agreed to lie.
这就是大家都同意去撒的那个谎。
And here's how it was going to go down. My Uncle Hai Bin's son, Liang-Liang, had recently married a Japanese woman. They planned to celebrate in China the next year, but now it would be in two weeks, and it would bring together family members who had not all been in the same place for 25 years.
事情就是这样进行的。我叔叔海斌的儿子亮亮最近娶了一位日本女性。他们原计划明年在中国庆祝，但现在提前到了两周后，这将把25年来从未聚在一起的家人们集合起来。
My dad told Nainai that the wedding banquet had to happen immediately because that was when the groom Liang-Liang could get the time off work.
我爸告诉奶奶，婚礼宴会必须马上举行，因为那时新郎亮亮正好能从工作中抽出时间。
How did you feel about lying?
你对自己撒谎有什么感觉？
Well, it's not, I mean, clear cut, this is a lie and that's-- you know. Because people think lie is bad thing. But in this circumstance, you don't think that you make a bad lie. You think you make a good lie because that's the way that everybody wants it. And that's the way that it's supposed to be.
嗯，这并不，我是说，并非黑白分明，这是谎言，那是——你知道的。因为人们认为撒谎是坏事。但在这种情况下，你不觉得你撒的是个坏谎。你觉得你撒的是个善意的谎言，因为那是每个人都想要的。而且事情本该如此。
But that wasn't the way I wanted it or thought it was supposed to be. And I still wasn't convinced it would be what Nainai wanted. I was so emotional that my mom said maybe I shouldn't go, that I might cry and blow the cover. I was afraid she might be right. But if I wanted to see Nainai before she died, I had to go, and I had to be part of the lie.
但这并不是我想要的，也不是我以为本该如此的方式。我仍然不确定这是否是奶奶想要的。我情绪太激动了，以至于妈妈说也许我不该去，我可能会哭出来而露馅。我担心她可能是对的。但如果我想在奶奶去世前见她，我就必须去，而且我必须成为这个谎言的一部分。
[AIRPORT SOUNDS]
[机场声音]
This is from a video I took. I started filming as soon as I landed. I brought the camcorder with me to hide behind, hoping it would help me to keep it together. At the arrivals gate, I heard Nainai shouting my name through the crowd. She wasn't difficult to spot-- a squat figure waving a pink handkerchief from the front of the crowd. She was at least a foot shorter than everyone else, and her white hair stood out.
这是我拍的一段视频。我一落地就开始拍摄。我带着摄像机是为了躲在后面，希望它能帮我控制情绪。在到达大厅，我听到奶奶在人群中喊我的名字。她不难被发现——一个矮小的身影，在人群前方挥舞着一条粉红色的手帕。她比其他人都矮至少一英尺，白发格外显眼。
"Oh, my granddaughter," she cried. She looked me up and down. You're not very skinny, she observed. Your mom says you've been very busy with work. I thought you'd be skinny, but you're not that skinny.
“哦，我的孙女，”她喊道。她打量着我。你一点都不瘦，她观察到。你妈说你工作一直很忙。我以为你会很瘦，但你并不怎么瘦。
Nainai didn't look or act like someone who was sick at all. I asked her how she was feeling, and she said she was doing well. She had some knee pain from the years she marched across the country with the People's Liberation Army when she was 14. If it weren't for my bad knees, she said, I'd be perfect.
奶奶看起来或者表现得一点也不像个病人。我问她感觉如何，她说她很好。她从14岁参加人民解放军长征以来，膝盖一直有些疼痛。要是没有这双坏膝盖，她说，我就完美了。
My parents were delayed in Beijing that night, but the rest of the family gathered around Nainai's dinner table. Little Nainai held her little white dog on her lap, a dog they call Ellen. They named Ellen after an American exchange student who had stayed with them.
我父母那天晚上在北京被延误了，但其他家人都聚在奶奶的餐桌旁。姨奶奶怀里抱着她的小白狗，一只他们叫“艾伦”的狗。他们给艾伦取名是因为一个曾经和他们住过的美国交换生。
[TALKING IN CHINESE]
[中文对话]
Ellen has one trick that she can normally do on command. Everyone here is yelling, "sing, Ellen! Sing, sing!" And then, finally--
艾伦有一个通常在命令下能做的把戏。每个人都在喊：“唱歌，艾伦！唱，唱！”然后，终于——
[DOG SQUEALING]
[狗叫声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[DOG SQUEALING]
[狗叫声]
After dinner, Uncle Hai Bin walked me to the nearby hotel where I was staying. Nainai is in one of the older neighborhoods in the area. There are still unpaved paths and small food stands, but her street is being slowly engulfed by shopping malls and high rises. "Nainai's very sick, you know," Uncle said as we walked. "She took care of you when you were little. She loves you so much."
晚饭后，海斌叔叔陪我走到我住的附近酒店。奶奶住在该地区较老的街区之一。那里还有未铺砌的小路和食品摊，但她的街道正被购物中心和高楼大厦缓慢吞噬。“奶奶病得很重，你知道吧，”叔叔走着时说。“你小的时候她照顾过你。她非常爱你。”
He kept saying things I already knew, things that felt like he was trying to provoke an emotion out of me. "You have to be very careful not to tell her," he said. "You'll feel very sad, but you cannot cry." Looking back, I wonder if he was really just trying to coach himself. "You have to be happy," he insisted. "I know," I said, as I stared straight ahead at the brightly lit billboards across the street.
他一直在说我已经知道的事情，那些听起来像是他试图激发出我的情绪的话。“你必须非常小心，不要告诉她，”他说。“你会觉得很伤心，但你不能哭。”回想起来，我怀疑他当时其实是在试图说服他自己。“你要表现得快乐，”他坚持说。“我知道，”我说，眼睛直视着街对面灯火通明的广告牌。
At most events, the emotional protocol is clear. You smile at weddings. You cry at funerals. The confusing thing here was that this was one situation masquerading as another. In China, you're actually expected to cry at a funeral-- a lot-- as a sign of respect. People judge you on how well you cry and how much you cry.
在大多数活动中，情感礼仪是很明确的。婚礼上你要微笑，葬礼上你要哭泣。这里令人困惑的是，这是一种伪装成另一种的情况。在中国，参加葬礼实际上是要求哭泣的——大声哭——作为一种尊敬的象征。人们会根据你哭得有多好、哭得有多久来评价你。
My uncle understood this protocol. At my grandfather Yeye's funeral in 1994, Uncle Hai Bin was tasked with the duty of performing a cathartic Chinese ritual to demonstrate his great grieving. As the eldest son, this was his designated role. He stood in the aisle in front of the coffin and raised a clay bowl over his head. While crying loudly, he smashed the bowl to the ground, shattering it into countless shards.
我叔叔理解这种礼仪。在1994年爷爷的葬礼上，海斌叔叔被指派负责执行一种情感宣泄的中国仪式来表达他的悲痛。作为长子，这是他指定的角色。他站在棺材前，把一个陶瓷碗举过头顶。在大哭的同时，他把碗摔在地上，砸得粉碎。
My mother hates these kinds of huge emotional displays, by the way. At her father's funeral, years ago, her family criticized her for not crying enough.
顺便说一句，我妈妈非常讨厌这种巨大的情感宣泄。多年以前在她父亲的葬礼上，她的家人曾批评她哭得不够。
The people over there, they expect you just fall on the floor and then like, like crazy people. And the shouting and crying, this is a Chinese part of, you know, their tradition. The people die, they hire the people. And if you have money, you can hire 100 people, come here, just cry. Say one, two, three, cry! And one, two, three, stop! I hate that.
那些人，他们期待你直接倒在地上，像疯子一样。喊叫和哭泣，这是中国传统的一部分。人死了，他们雇人哭。如果你有钱，你可以雇100个人过来，喊：一、二、三，哭！然后喊：一、二、三，停！我讨厌这个。
[PEOPLE CHATTING IN CHINESE]
[中文聊天声]
The next morning, my parents finally arrive. I'm videotaping as Nainai greets my dad at the door, asking him all kinds of questions about his flight, about a recent dental surgery he had. The rest of the family hovers close by, and I can see that my dad is so emotional that he can't say a single word. He can't even look her in the eyes. He tries to be playful and takes off her hat, then fiddles with his own sunglasses, trying to distract himself. Later, I was finally able to ask him what he was feeling when he walked through that door.
第二天早上，我父母终于到了。我在摄像时，奶奶在门口迎接爸爸，问了他关于航班的各种问题，还有他最近做的牙科手术。其他家人聚在一旁，我能看出爸爸太难过了，说不出一句话来。他甚至不敢直视她的眼睛。他试图表现得活跃一点，摘下她的帽子，然后摆弄着自己的太阳镜，试图分散自己的注意力。后来，我终于能问他走进那扇门时是什么感觉。
Well, you know, it's just like every son, feeling that your mom is dying, and you cannot tell and thinking that that's probably the last time that you'll see your mom. All the family is around you. Everybody is there. And everybody knows what's going on except your grandma, except my mom.
嗯，你知道，就像每个儿子一样，感到你的母亲快要去世了，你却不能说，而且想到这可能是你最后一次见到你的母亲。所有的家人都在你周围。每个人都在那儿。除了你奶奶，除了我妈，每个人都知道发生了什么。
I was afraid to say something, then you cannot hold myself, and I'll start crying, right? You want to say something, but you don't know what to say. It's just now, there's no words to choose from.
我当时怕说出点什么，然后就控制不住自己，开始哭了，对吧？你想说什么，但你不知道该说什么。就是现在，已经没有合适的词可以选择了。
At one point, Nainai asks him, "what's wrong?" Even though he doesn't respond, it's like she can feel the weight of his grief, and she just starts sobbing. I wondered if she knew why we were all there. Or maybe when you're 80, this is just how you greet your son who lives so far away.
有一次，奶奶问他：“怎么了？”即使他没有回答，也像是她能感受到他悲伤的重量，然后她就开始抽泣。我不知道她是否知道我们为什么要聚在这里。或者，当你80岁的时候，这就是迎接远道而来的儿子的方式。
There are other relatives around, and my dad walks away from Nainai to get some space. On the video, you can hear my mom interject, her voice upbeat, trying to lighten the mood.
周围还有其他亲戚，我爸爸离开奶奶身边去腾出点空间。在视频里，你可以听到我妈妈插话，语气轻快，试图缓和气氛。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文对话]
After a while, Nainai takes her usual role as the matriarch and gathers everyone around, taking charge. She reminds us why we're all here-- the big event of Liang-Liang and his wife's marriage. Yes, Liang-Liang's wedding is the big event, my dad confirms quietly.
过了一会儿，奶奶恢复了她作为家长的角色，把大家聚在一起，掌控全局。她提醒我们为什么大家会在这儿——为了亮亮和他妻子的那件大事。是的，亮亮的婚礼是件大事，我爸爸安静地确认道。
We all urge Nainai to relax, but she's busy giving everyone their priorities. You check on the banquet hall. You guys need to prepare your wedding speeches. You need to get over your jet lag.
我们都催促奶奶休息，但她忙着给每个人安排优先事项。你去查一下宴会厅。你们需要准备婚礼演讲。你们需要克服时差。
[NAINAI SPEAKING CHINESE]
[奶奶中文对话]
Seeing Nainai, who probably should be in the hospital, get so worked up over this phony wedding banquet while we stood by and watched, it felt cruel. I went to Nainai's niece, who I call Gugu, with my concerns. Gugu lives close by and also helps look after Nainai.
看着本该在医院的奶奶，却为了这个虚假的婚宴忙前忙后，而我们站在一边看着，这感觉很残忍。我带着疑虑找到了奶奶的侄女，我叫她姑姑。姑姑住在附近，也负责照顾奶奶。
I asked her, "what if Nainai has things she wants to take care of?" "Like what," Gugu responded. I said, "I don't know. None of us do. That's my whole point." "No," Gugu said. She doesn't have anything like that. And that was the end of the discussion.
我问她：“如果奶奶有她想处理的事情怎么办？”“比如什么？”姑姑反问道。我说：“我不知道。我们谁都不知道。这正是我的重点。”“不，”姑姑说。“她没有什么那种事。”讨论就这样结束了。
The wedding celebration was held in the banquet hall of a newly-built hotel. Liang-Liang had on a black suit with a pale pink tie. His Japanese wife wore a blue chiffon dress with a floral shawl. Guests approached Nainai to congratulate her, smiling. Like a politician at a press event, Nainai smiled back. She shook hands. She kissed babies.
婚礼庆祝活动在一家新建酒店的宴会厅举行。亮亮穿着黑色西装，系着浅粉色领带。他的日本妻子穿着蓝色雪纺裙，披着花披肩。客人们带着微笑上前向奶奶祝贺。像政客参加新闻发布会一样，奶奶回以微笑。她握手，亲吻婴儿。
When it came time for the speeches, Uncle Hai Bin, my dad's brother, took to the stage first. He fumbled a while with the microphone before looking up. "It's a rare opportunity for us all to be here today," he started. "You all knew Liang-Liang as a young child, before we left China. And now, he's become a man. He's brought a wife back with him from Japan."
轮到演讲时，我爸爸的哥哥海斌叔叔首先走上台。他在找麦克风的时候摸索了一会儿，然后抬头看着说：“这是我们大家今天在这里难得的机会，”他开始说。“你们都在亮亮小时候见过他，在我们离开中国之前。现在，他已经成为一个男人了。他带着从日本娶来的妻子回来了。”
Uncle motioned to Liang-Liang's wife, who couldn't understand a word of Chinese. "I think we are all hoping that next time they return, they will carry with them a baby or two." The room chuckled. Liang-Liang translated this to his wife, and her face flushed.
叔叔示意了一下亮亮的妻子，她一句中文也听不懂。“我想我们都在期待，下次他们回来时，会带着一两个孩子。”房间里传出了笑声。亮亮把这话翻译给他妻子听，她的脸涨红了。
"There's just one more thing," Uncle said, his voice starting to quiver. "They say that a mother's greatest joy is having her children by her side. My ma has sadly not had that fortune" -- he meant because he and my dad lived so far away -- "So she is lucky to have all of you to care for her."
“还有一件事，”叔叔说，声音开始颤抖。“人们说，做母亲最大的快乐就是孩子在身边。我妈很遗憾没有那个福气”——他的意思是说因为我和我爸住得太远——“所以，能有你们大家照顾她，她很幸运。”
He stared at Nainai in the audience, and then, as if in slow motion, tears began to stream down his face. I thought of Uncle Hai Bin at Yeye's funeral, gripping that clay bowl over his head as everyone watched, anticipating the explosion into a thousand pieces. But this wasn't a funeral. It was a wedding. No crying, only happy. He had warned me himself just the night before.
他盯着台下的奶奶，然后，像是慢动作一样，眼泪开始从他脸上流下来。我想到海斌叔叔在爷爷葬礼上，双手抓着那个陶瓷碗的样子，当时每个人都在看着，期待着那声破碎的爆响。但这并不是葬礼，这是婚礼。不能哭，只能开心。头天晚上他自己还警告过我。
They were all watching. Nainai was watching. There was no turning back. "Everything I am, everything I've become is because of my ma." This releases the dam. He begins to weep uncontrollably on stage, his shoulders shaking.
他们都在看着。奶奶在看着。已经没有回头路了。“我的一切，我的成就，都是因为我妈。”这冲垮了堤坝。他在台上开始无法抑制地痛哭，肩膀不停地颤抖。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
"Ma, you're the best mom in the entire world." I looked over at Nainai, who dabbed at her eyes with her handkerchief. Was she moved? Was she suspicious? Looking at her, I couldn't tell.
“妈，你是世界上最好的妈妈。”我看向奶奶，她用手帕擦着眼睛。她感动了吗？她怀疑了吗？看着她，我无法判断。
After the speeches, the bride and groom moved from table to table making toasts. It didn't take a mind reader to see that Nainai didn't like the new Japanese wife. "I think she's quite dumb," Nainai said. "She doesn't understand anything." "That's because she doesn't speak Chinese," I reminded her. "No, she insisted. It's because she's dumb."
演讲结束后，新郎新娘挨桌敬酒。不用读心术也能看出奶奶不喜欢这个新的日本媳妇。“我觉得她挺笨的，”奶奶说。“她什么都不懂。”“那是因为她不会说中文，”我提醒她。“不，”她坚持说。“是因为她笨。”
The bride and groom weren't used to the heavy drinking rituals of the northern Chinese and got drunk fast. I mean, they had to drink at every single table. Liang-Liang, the groom, constantly looked like he was about to cry. And after the drinking, he could no longer hold it in.
新郎新娘不习惯中国北方强烈的饮酒礼仪，很快就喝醉了。我的意思是，他们每一桌都得喝。新郎亮亮看起来一直像快要哭出来一样。喝完之后，他再也忍不住了。
He started to bawl until his face turned bright red. His wife's eyes were wide with panic as she scanned the room for help. Gugu motioned wildly to me from across the room as we all swooped in to try and form a barricade around the sobbing groom. We told Nainai that Liang-Liang was probably just too happy, that he was crying tears of joy.
他开始嚎啕大哭，脸涨得通红。他妻子的眼睛里满是恐慌，在房间里扫视着寻求帮助。姑姑从房间对面狂乱地向我招手，我们所有人蜂拥而上，试图围成一个路障挡住大哭的新郎。我们告诉奶奶，亮亮可能只是太高兴了，他是喜极而泣。
The night after the wedding, we all went out to a restaurant. After a massive feast, we played a drinking game.
婚礼后的第二天晚上，我们全家去了一家餐馆。在饱餐一顿之后，我们玩了一个喝酒游戏。
[TALKING IN CHINESE]
[中文对话]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Nainai laughed so hard that she cried, and then laughed some more. It was hard to distinguish which smiles were real and which ones were faked for Nainai's sake. While I struggled with the grief of saying goodbye, Nainai focused on the future, a future she assumed she'd be part of. "When you get married," she told me, "I'll have an even bigger wedding banquet for you." She also asked when I'd have a baby, saying that she was looking forward to holding my child.
奶奶笑得直掉眼泪，然后又笑了一阵。很难区分哪些微笑是真的，哪些是为了奶奶而假装的。虽然我努力克服道别的悲伤，但奶奶专注于未来，她认为她会参与其中的未来。“当你结婚时，”她对我说，“我会为你举办一场更大的婚宴。”她还问我什么时候生孩子，说她很期待能抱抱我的孩子。
I had no idea when any of that might happen, but I played along. We planned what my wedding banquet would look like and talked about how to balance my career once I had this hypothetical kid. Lying made me sick to my stomach.
我不知道这些事情什么时候会发生，但我配合着她。我们规划了我的婚宴会是什么样，谈论了在有了这个假设的孩子后如何平衡我的事业。撒谎让我感到胃里一阵翻江倒海。
"Listen," my mom tried to reassure me, "your Nainai would appreciate that we're lying to her. Otherwise, why would she have done the same thing to your grandfather?" This was the first time I'd heard of this. I was only 10 when Yeye was diagnosed with liver cancer.
“听着，”我妈妈试图安慰我，“你奶奶会感激我们对她撒谎的。不然，她为什么当初也对你爷爷做同样的事？”这是我第一次听说这件事。爷爷被诊断出肝癌时，我才10岁。
As it turns out, no one told him about his condition, either. As his wife, Nainai was the key decision-maker in that situation. He had severe jaundice and was barely lucid when Nainai finally gave him the bad news in the hospital. "I need to tell you something, old-timer," she began. He succumbed to the cancer three days later.
结果证明，也没人告诉他病情。作为妻子，奶奶在那个情况下是关键决策者。爷爷黄疸很严重，奶奶最终在医院告诉他坏消息时，他几乎神志不清了。“老头子，我得告诉你点事，”她开始说。三天后，他死于癌症。
I asked my dad about this, and he said, in truth, Yeye knew. No one told him, but deep down, people can feel when they're really dying. They knew, and he knew, but everyone pretended not to know so they could all allow each other to save face. So did Nainai also know? Was she also lying to us?
我问爸爸这件事，他说，说实话，爷爷知道。没人告诉他，但内心深处，人是能感觉到自己是否真的快要死了。他们知道，他也知道，但每个人都假装不知道，这样大家都能互相给个面子。那么奶奶也知道吗？她也在对我们撒谎吗？
Later, Little Nainai told me that there was, in fact, a secret that Nainai had kept from us.
后来，姨奶奶告诉我，事实上，有一个奶奶一直瞒着我们的秘密。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
[中文对话]
That's the sound of me being totally shocked. She tells me that in 2007, six years before the lung cancer diagnosis, Nainai had been diagnosed with breast cancer, not unusual for a woman in her 70s. But my dad didn't know. My uncle didn't know. I didn't know.
那是被彻底震惊到的我的声音。她告诉我，2007年，也就是肺癌诊断前六年，奶奶曾被诊断出患有乳腺癌，这对70多岁的女性来说并不罕见。但我爸不知道。我叔叔不知道。我不知道。
She had a mastectomy, and she'd been wearing a prosthetic breast for nine years. Nainai concealed this from our family and uncle's family not because she was ashamed, but so that we wouldn't worry. All this time that we were lying to her to protect her, she had also put on a show to protect us.
她做了乳房切除术，并且戴了九年的义乳。奶奶向我们家和叔叔家隐瞒了这一点，不是因为羞耻，而是为了不让我们担心。当我们一直为了保护她而对她撒谎时，她也一直在演戏来保护我们。
After I left China, I immediately Skyped Nainai from home. "I love you," she said in English, the few words that she knows. I managed to find time to Skype with her every day, just to check in. At first, she seemed to be doing fine and had no symptoms. Then one day, she started to cough, and my heart sank. "I just have a bit of the flu," she said. "It's nothing."
我离开中国后，立刻在家里通过Skype和奶奶视频。“我爱你，”她用英语说，这是她会的为数不多的几个词。我设法每天抽出时间通过Skype和她联络，只是为了问候一下。起初，她看起来做得很好，没有任何症状。后来有一天，她开始咳嗽，我的心沉了下去。“我只是有点感冒，”她说。“没什么。”
When the cough wouldn't go away, she suggested going to the doctor's office to pick up some medicine. Little Nainai panicked and immediately talked her out of it. But then, a few days later, Nainai stopped coughing. Three months came and went, and Nainai was still just fine. Everyone was baffled.
当咳嗽一直不好时，她提议去诊所拿点药。姨奶奶慌了，立刻劝阻了她。但几天后，奶奶停止了咳嗽。三个月转瞬即逝，奶奶依然很好。大家都困惑不解。
Eventually, I couldn't keep up with the daily Skype calls, and it dwindled down to once a week, and then once a month. A year passed. Nainai said she felt fine, so she just decided to skip her annual checkup that year. And another year passed.
最终，我没能跟上每天的Skype通话，减到了一周一次，然后是一个月一次。一年过去了。奶奶说她感觉很好，所以她干脆决定那年跳过年度体检。又一年过去了。
During her 2015 checkup, the same doctor gave the same diagnosis and prognosis-- stage 4 lung cancer, very serious, no more than three months. This time, Little Nainai didn't even bother to mock up a phony document. She just told Nainai that she had lost the test results, but that everything was the same. Everything was fine.
在2015年的体检中，同一个医生给出了同样的诊断和预后——肺癌晚期，非常严重，最多三个月。这一次，姨奶奶甚至懒得再编造虚假病历了。她只是告诉奶奶她丢了化验单，但结果和以前一样。一切都很好。
It's been three years now since Nainai was first diagnosed. Little Nainai is certain her big sister is still alive because of her decision to lie to her, because we gave Nainai joy instead of worry. My mom told me about an old Chinese belief called chongxi. Chong means to rinse out, and xi is joy. So chongxi is the belief that you can wash away a misfortune with joy. Even though this term was never used while planning the wedding, that's essentially what we did.
从奶奶第一次被诊断出来到现在已经三年了。姨奶奶确信她的姐姐依然活着，是因为她决定对她撒谎，因为我们给了奶奶快乐而不是忧虑。妈妈告诉我一个古老的中国信仰，叫“冲喜”。冲是洗掉，喜是快乐。所以冲喜就是相信你可以用快乐来冲走厄运。虽然在策划婚礼时从未用到这个词，但我们做的本质上就是这个。
And by the way, everyone in the family has their own idea of what saved Nainai. Gugu thinks it's partly because of her weekly prayers at the local Taoist temple. My uncle credits Nainai's survival to some expensive miracle probiotics he bought her from Japan. Since Nainai seemed to be doing fine, my parents suggested getting a less expensive brand of probiotics, and Uncle Hai Bin being freaked out. "If we switch it and she dies, then it's on you."
顺便提一下，家里的每个人都有各自拯救奶奶的理由。姑姑认为这部分是因为她在当地道观的每周祈祷。我叔叔把奶奶的存活归功于他从日本买给奶奶的昂贵的神奇益生菌。由于奶奶似乎做得很好，我父母建议买一种便宜点的品牌，海斌叔叔吓坏了。“如果我们换了，她去世了，那就要怪你。”
When this whole thing started, I felt like the only rational person in my family, the lone westerner defending my grandmother against old-fashioned beliefs. As it turns out, my mom agreed with me. But she and my dad just understand both sides.
当这一切开始时，我觉得自己是家里唯一理性的人，是捍卫祖母、对抗过时信仰的孤独西方人。事实证明，我妈妈是同意我的。但她和爸爸只是理解两边的看法。
I'm pretty sure a lot of other Americans would feel the way that I felt, that somebody's going to die. It's their right to know.
我很确定很多其他美国人会有我那种感觉，如果有人快要死了，他们有权知道。
Yeah. But we just think that's not your business. You not live with her, and so--
是的。但我们只是觉得那不关你的事。你没和她住在一起，所以——
OK. But do you understand where I was coming from? Do you understand why I was conflicted?
好吧。但你们理解我当时为什么会那样吗？你们理解我为什么会感到矛盾吗？
Yeah. I know. But that's China. That's a different world, OK? People go into a funeral, and you have to hold a pillow around the house three times. And in this country, you don't do that, right? So you not use your culture to push to them. This make chaos.
是的。我知道。但那是中国。那是一个不同的世界，好吗？人们去参加葬礼，你得抱着枕头绕屋子走三圈。在这个国家，你不做那种事，对吧？所以你不能用你的文化去强加给他们。这会制造混乱。
I wonder now if my mom or dad was diagnosed with something terminal and I knew and they didn't, would I lie to them? And if it was me, would I want to know? What my family did was kind, and it worked-- maybe. I'm reminded of a joke about a physicist visiting his colleague, Niels Bohr, and expressed his surprise at finding a good-luck horseshoe hanging on the wall. "Surely you're not superstitious?" "Oh, no," Niels Bohr says. "But I'm told it works whether you believe in it or not." I know that doesn't seem like a joke, but you know what I'm saying.
我现在想，如果我父母被诊断出绝症，我已知情而他们不知情，我会撒谎吗？如果是我自己，我会想知道吗？我家人所做的是善良的，而且奏效了——也许吧。我想到一个关于物理学家拜访同事尼尔斯·玻尔的笑话，他表达了对墙上挂着好运马蹄铁的惊讶。“你一定不迷信吧？”“哦，不，”尼尔斯·玻尔说。“但我听说，不管你信不信，它都管用。”我知道这听起来不像个笑话，但你知道我是在说什么。
[BEEP]
[哔]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文对话]
Lulu Wang. She's a filmmaker. Her first feature, called Posthumous , comes out this summer. Coming up, the stuff that all of us don't know we don't know, a scientist actually tries to measure it. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
露露·王。她是一位电影制片人。她的首部剧情长片名为《Posthumous》，将于今年夏天上映。接下来说说我们大家都不知道自己不知道的事，一位科学家试图去测量它。节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, In Defense of Ignorance, stories making the case for not knowing-- a case, I admit, you do not hear very often. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Ignorance for Dummies.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“为无知辩护”，故事讲述了“不知道”的情况——我承认，你平时很少听到这样的观点。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“无知小白”。
So in the first half of our show, we heard a woman who was kept in ignorance by her family. In this half of the show, we're going to turn to people who are just ignorant. They just don't know stuff, and they don't know what they don't know, which-- hello-- turns out to be all of us. Sean Cole has details and empirical data.
在节目的前半部分，我们听到了一个被家人隐瞒真相的女性的故事。在节目的这一部分，我们将转向那些本身就是无知的人。他们就是不知道一些事情，而且他们也不知道自己不知道什么，这——嘿——事实证明那就是我们所有人。肖恩·科尔带来了详细信息和实证数据。
There's this story about ignorance that David Dunning really loves. He's a psychology professor, and he's even cited it in his research. It's about a guy named McArthur Wheeler, who in 1995 robbed a couple of banks in Pennsylvania and didn't wear a mask.
有一个关于无知的故事，戴维·邓宁非常喜欢。他是一位心理学教授，甚至在研究中引用过它。这是关于一个叫麦克阿瑟·惠勒的人，他在1995年抢劫了宾夕法尼亚州的几家银行，而且没有戴面具。
And he was arrested. And the police basically said, "well, we have you on the surveillance tapes." And he said, "no, you don't." And they showed him the tapes. And he saw his face. And he stared incredulously and said, "but I wore the juice. I wore the juice."
他被捕了。警察基本上说：“嗯，我们在监控录像上拍到你了。”他说：“没有，你们没有。”他们把录像放给他看。他看到了自己的脸。他难以置信地盯着看，说：“但我涂了汁。我涂了汁。”
The juice?
汁？
Yes. Apparently, McArthur Wheeler was under the impression that smearing your face with lemon juice made it fuzzy or invisible to video cameras. To his credit, he had actually tested this theory. He took a selfie, but I think he misaimed the camera.
是的。显然，麦克阿瑟·惠勒以为把柠檬汁涂在脸上会让脸变得模糊或对摄像机隐形。值得赞扬的是，他确实测试过这个理论。他拍了张自拍照，但我认为他没对准镜头。
The thing about McArthur Wheeler wasn't just that he was an idiot. It was that he thought he was doing everything right, which made David Dunning think--
麦克阿瑟·惠勒的问题不仅在于他是个白痴。关键在于他以为自己做的一切都是对的，这让戴维·邓宁思考——
When people are wrong or when they're performing poorly or, for lack of a better word, when they're incompetent, do they know they're incompetent?
当人们犯错，或者表现不佳，或者用一个更好的词来说，当他们能力不足时，他们知道自己能力不足吗？
And he had a guess, which was no. They do not know they're incompetent.
他有一个猜测，那就是不会。他们不知道自己能力不足。
And so we decided to do some experiments and find out.
所以我们决定做一些实验来找出答案。
Now, this may not sound like something you can easily test for. It's like trying to measure the height and weight of somebody's insecurity. But Professor Dunning and his grad student partner, Justin Kruger, figured out a way to do it.
这听起来可能不是容易测试的东西。这就像试图测量一个人的不安全感的高度和重量一样。但邓宁教授和他的研究生搭档贾斯汀·克鲁格想出了一种方法。
They got different groups of undergrads together-- this was at Cornell University-- and gave them one of three quizzes. One was on grammar, another on logical reasoning, and another, weirdly, on humor-- like, which one of these jokes is the funniest? And they had a panel of comedians write the jokes ahead of time.
他们找来了不同的本科生群体——这是在康奈尔大学——给他们做了三项测试之一。一个是语法，一个是逻辑推理，还有一个奇怪地是幽默——比如，这些笑话里哪一个最好笑？他们之前找了一群喜剧演员来写这些笑话。
And at the end of the quizzes, they asked each student a simple question-- how well do you think you did? Or more specifically, in what percentile did you land? That is, what percentage of the other students taking the test do you think you beat? And then they gathered together all of that data and ran the numbers.
测试结束时，他们问每个学生一个简单的问题——你认为你做得怎么样？或者更具体地说，你觉得你排在第几百分位？也就是说，你认为你超过了百分之多少参加测试的其他学生？然后他们收集了所有数据并进行了计算。
And I still remember looking at the first graph to this day. And the big finding is we took a look at the bottom 25% of people in each study. These are the people who had done the worst. Their scores are falling in the 11th, the 12th, the 13th percentile.
直到今天，我还记得看着第一张图表时的情景。最大的发现是，我们看了一下每项研究中表现最差的25%的人。这些是表现最糟的人。他们的分数落在第11、第12、第13百分位。
In other words, really low scores.
换句话说，是非常低的分数。
But they think they're performing in the 60th, the 65th, the 70th percentile.
但他们认为自己处于第60、第65、第70百分位。
Among the better percentiles.
处于更好的百分位。
That's right. They think that they've beat out a majority of their peers. One way to think about it-- if you look at people basically who are about to get D's and F's with the exam they've just handed in, they think they're getting B's, B-pluses with the exam they just handed in.
没错。他们认为自己超过了大部分同龄人。换一种思考方式——如果你看那些刚交上去的试卷基本要得D和F的人，他们以为自己刚交上去的试卷能得B或B+。
In short, there seemed to be a direct correlation between incompetence and an overweening sense of self-confidence. It wasn't apparent in every poor-performing student, but it was in the majority of them. Most people who did badly thought they did just fine or even great. They had no idea.
简而言之，能力不足与过度的自信感之间似乎存在直接关联。这并非在每个表现差的学生身上都明显，但在大多数人身上确实如此。大多数表现糟糕的人认为自己做得还可以，甚至很棒。他们完全不知道（自己的水平）。
Now, anybody who's ever gone to school, worked a job, or known any other people knows this phenomenon. There's that guy or lady who's cocky and yet has no idea what they're doing, and it's infuriating. But here in Dunning's lab, it wasn't just an annoyance. It was a repeatable finding.
现在，任何上过学、做过工作或认识其他人的人都知道这种现象。总有那么一两个自负却又不知道自己在干什么的人，这非常令人恼火。但在邓宁的实验室里，这不仅仅是恼人。这是一个可重复的发现。
They did this experiment four times with four different groups of students, and it happened every time. Bottom performers thought they were at least above average. And in 1999, Dunning and Kruger published their findings in a paper called "Unskilled and Unaware of It."
他们用四个不同的学生群体重复了这个实验四次，每次都发生了同样的事。表现最差的人认为自己至少高于平均水平。1999年，邓宁和克鲁格在一篇名为《能力不足且对此一无所知》的论文中发表了他们的发现。
And their conclusion was this-- when someone asks, so how do you think you did, and you open your mouth to answer, you're drawing on the same skill set to answer that question that you used to answer the questions on the test.
他们的结论是这样的——当有人问，你觉得你做得怎么样，而你张嘴回答时，你在回答这个问题时所调用的技能与你回答测试问题时所调用的技能是同一套。
That is, the lack of skill means not only are you going to make a lot of mistakes, but it also means you're not going to be able to catch mistakes, yours or anybody else's. You're going to think, often, that what you're saying is absolutely reasonable. This is the double curse.
也就是说，缺乏技能不仅意味着你会犯很多错误，也意味着你无法察觉错误，无论是你自己的还是别人的。你经常会以为，你所说的绝对合理。这就是双重诅咒。
It's not that you're ignorant and also happen to be overconfident. You're ignorant, and it makes you overconfident. On the other hand, students who scored well, who really were in the higher percentiles, they tended to guess that they scored a little worse than they actually did, and for kind of an endearing reason.
并不是因为你无知又碰巧过度自信。你是无知，而这导致了你的过度自信。另一方面，得分高、真正处于较高百分位的学生，往往会猜测自己的分数比实际分数稍微差一点点，而且有一个可爱的理由。
They figured most of the kids around them knew as much as they did. In other words, they weren't mistaken about themselves. They knew themselves pretty well. They simply misjudged other people, thinking, well, they're probably as smart as I am.
他们认为周围的大多数孩子都和他们一样了解这些知识。换句话说，他们对自己并没有判断失误。他们对自己相当了解。他们只是误判了别人，认为，好吧，他们可能像我一样聪明。
Over the years, Dunning and other researchers have run the same experiment in different ways over and over again. And the result was pervasive-- competitive debaters who were doing badly didn't know they were doing badly, people at chess tournaments, trap and skeet shooters when they're quizzed on gun safety, medical professionals. Medical professionals.
多年来，邓宁和其他研究人员以各种方式一遍又一遍地进行了同样的实验。结果是普遍存在的——表现不佳的竞技辩论者不知道自己表现不佳，国际象棋比赛中的棋手，在进行枪支安全测试时的飞碟射击选手，医疗专业人员。医疗专业人员。
You'll find for some procedures, for example, that the interns-- like catheterization procedures.
例如，你会发现对于某些程序，实习生——比如导尿程序。
[DRAWING BREATH]
[吸气声]
Exactly. 80% of them think they know this technique so well they can teach it to other people, whereas zero of their instructors agree. In fact, 50% of their instructors say, no. This person needs still to be supervised whenever they do this.
没错。他们中80%的人认为自己掌握这种技术非常熟练，可以教给别人，而他们的教练们没有人同意。事实上，50%的教练说，不。这个人做这个时仍然需要被监督。
Oy gevalt!
哎哟！
Yeah.
是的。
And like all psychological phenomenon, this one pretty quickly grew a name. Dunning was insistent that he and Kruger had nothing to do with the coining of that name. The name-- the Dunning-Kruger Effect.
像所有心理学现象一样，这个现象很快就有了一个名字。邓宁坚持说，他和克鲁格与这个名字的命名无关。这个名字——“邓宁-克鲁格效应”。
If you, for example, go on Twitter and type in Dunning-Kruger, you'll see the effect mentioned several times a day.
如果你在Twitter上输入“邓宁-克鲁格”，你每天会看到这个效应被提及好几次。
Several times a day?
一天好几次？
Several times a day.
一天好几次。
Well, I have a computer in front of me. And I'm going to Twitter. And let me just put in Dunning-Kruger. Oh, here we go. Trump is a static display of Dunning-Kruger in effect. Where did you get your biology PhD, Dunning-Kruger University? Your clueless rants merely reinforce your ignorance.
嗯，我面前有台电脑。我要去Twitter上看看。让我输入“邓宁-克鲁格”。哦，这儿呢。“特朗普是邓宁-克鲁格效应的静态展示。”“你在哪儿拿到的生物学博士？邓宁-克鲁格大学吗？”“你那无知的胡言乱语只会加强你的无知。”
No, so very happy to get a meme out there in the world, unhappy that so many people use it as an epithet.
不，很高兴在这个世界上有一个梗，但很不高兴这么多人把它当作一种谩骂。
That it's your name that they're using as an epithet.
他们用你的名字作为一种谩骂。
Exactly.
没错。
It's just become a scientific way of calling somebody stupid, which I guess we were sorely in need of.
它已经变成了称呼别人愚蠢的一种科学方式，我想这正是我们急需的。
But I think the thing that people in general miss is that we're not talking about the brain of the incompetent. We're talking about the brain of all of us because sooner or later, we step into that group. Sooner or later, we become the poor performers.
但我认为大家通常忽视的一点是，我们谈论的并不是能力不足者的脑子。我们谈论的是我们所有人的脑子，因为迟早，我们都会踏入那个群体。迟早，我们会成为表现不佳的人。
We all have our specific pockets of incompetence, and we know some of them. But there are a lot of them we simply don't know. And once we step into our own incompetence, we don't know we've made the step.
我们每个人都有特定的无知领域，有些我们知道，但有很多我们根本不知道。一旦我们踏入了我们自己的无知中，我们甚至不知道自己已经跨出了那一步。
This is really the disheartening stoner insight of this research. If you think you're doing well, it means one of two things-- either you're doing well or you're not doing well at all. Try not to think about it too long. Really. David Dunning, who has thought about it more than anyone, says it's made him particularly vigilant about the things he says and does and how he acts, like trying to catch a candid glimpse of yourself in a mirror.
这确实是这项研究中令人沮丧的、像抽了烟一样的顿悟。如果你以为自己做得很好，这意味着两件事之一——要么你做得真的很好，要么你根本就做得一塌糊涂。尽量别想太久。真的。戴维·邓宁思考过这个问题比任何人都多，他说这让他对自己的言行变得格外警惕，就像试图在镜子里捕捉自己真实、不加修饰的样子。
This one time for instance, he was teaching a class, giving them an exam. And at the end of it, he asked the students the Dunning-Kruger question-- how do you think you did? And sure enough, when he looked back at the tests, he noticed this one kid in particular who got one of the lowest grades in the group and rated himself in the 80th percentile.
比如有一次，他在上课，给学生考试。考试结束时，他问了学生那个“邓宁-克鲁格”问题——你觉得你考得怎么样？果然，当他看回试卷时，他注意到一个特别的孩子，他考了该组中最低的分数之一，却评价自己处于第80百分位。
And I decided, well I am going to peek at the name because I just have a suspicion I'm going to see this person in my office. And indeed, when the test was handed back, he did come into my office because he did want to offer me a chance, graciously, to admit that the answers that I had designated as correct on the exam were actually wrong.
我决定，好吧，我要瞄一眼名字，因为我有一种预感，这个人会出现在我的办公室。确实，当试卷发还时，他真的进了我的办公室，因为他想给我一个机会，很体面地，让我承认我在试卷上指定的那些正确答案实际上是错的。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And so he was really trying hard to be gracious. I could see some vibrations of outrage in his body. And part of my brain is going, watch this. Analyze this. What's going on? What's psychologically happening?
他真的很努力地表现得体面。我能看到他身体里散发出愤怒的波动。我大脑的一部分在说：看着。分析这个。发生了什么？心理上正在发生什么？
Then I've got another part of my brain kind of going, are you sure it's not you? Are you sure it's not you? Because I think it would be embarrassing for a person who has proposed the Dunning-Kruger framework to actually publicly display Dunning-Kruger.
然后我大脑的另一部分又在想：你确定那不是你吗？你确定那不是你吗？因为我觉得，一个提出“邓宁-克鲁格”框架的人如果在公开场合表现出邓宁-克鲁格现象，那会很尴尬。
But the sad, sad truth is what I'd dearly love would be to be able to see me in this circumstance, to be aware of, OK. I am having a Dunning-Kruger moment. But according to my own theory, I'll never have it.
但可悲、可悲的事实是，我最渴望的会是能够在这种情况下看到我自己，能够意识到，好吧，我正在经历一个“邓宁-克鲁格”时刻。但根据我自己的理论，我永远也不可能意识到。
That's because other people can see when we're doing the Dunning-Kruger dance, but we can't. Which makes you think, why doesn't anybody say anything? When it's little stuff-- your fly is down, you have stuff on your face-- your real friends, and even some strangers, will tell you.
这是因为当我们在跳“邓宁-克鲁格”之舞时，别人能看出来，而我们自己却看不出来。这让你想到，为什么没有人说点什么呢？当这是小事时——你的拉链没拉，脸上沾了东西——你真正的朋友，甚至一些陌生人，都会告诉你。
But somehow, when you're blowing a huge word balloon full of wrongness, that's when the rest of us decide to be polite, to go along. Because to correct that weirdly confident, know-nothing jerk in the office just seems mean, like it's not our place. But maybe it's meaner not to correct him.
但不知何故，当你吹起一个充满错误的巨大气球时，那正是我们其他人决定礼貌对待、随声附和的时候。因为去纠正办公室里那个奇怪地自信、一无所知的混蛋似乎很刻薄，好像那不是我们该管的事。但也许，不纠正他更刻薄。
The real sadness, for me, is that often, people are going to suffer for their mistakes. But they're never going to know it because if a person is a jerk in the office, what happens is all the parties they aren't invited to, all the wonderful social interactions, they just don't get to experience. And it's likely that they don't notice the absence of this.
对我来说，真正的悲哀是，通常人们会因为自己的错误而受苦。但他们永远不会知道，因为如果一个人在办公室里是个混蛋，发生的事情就是所有他没被邀请参加的派对，所有精彩的社交互动，他都无法体验。而且很可能，他根本注意不到这些缺席。
So you don't know you're incompetent. You can't figure it out on your own. And the world is treating you by being silent. Well, how do you improve yourself under those conditions?
所以你不知道自己能力不足。你无法靠自己弄明白。而世界通过沉默来对待你。好吧，在这种条件下，你如何提升自己呢？
I should say that Dunning and Kruger's research has been criticized over the years. Other researchers have tried to punch holes in their conclusion, even going so far as to publish papers with alternative statistical explanations for Dunning and Kruger's findings.
我应该说，邓宁和克鲁格的研究多年来一直受到批评。其他研究人员试图戳穿他们的结论，甚至写文章提出其他的统计学解释来反驳他们的发现。
And Dunning says he and his partner have responded to those critics, in print, and may have convinced some, but certainly not all of them, which he actually takes to be a plus. Because the critics they haven't convinced are really confident in their opinions. And Dunning and Kruger are really confident in theirs. So one or the other is dead wrong and just doesn't know it.
邓宁说，他和搭档在印刷品中回复了那些批评者，可能说服了一些人，但肯定没有说服所有人，他实际上把这看作是一个加分项。因为那些没被说服的批评者对自己的观点非常自信。而邓宁和克鲁格对自己观点也非常自信。所以他们之中肯定有一方错得离谱，而且就是不知道自己错了。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three, Forget Me Not. Our program today is about ignorance. And of course, a huge part of all of our ignorance is the stuff that we used to know that we've all forgotten.
第三幕，勿忘我。我们今天的节目是关于无知的。当然，我们所有无知中很大一部分，是我们曾经知道但现在已经忘记的东西。
All our lives, there's a huge undertow of forgetting that sucks old classmates' names into the abyss, the French that we studied that we never used, and the plots and casts of favorite movies we used to love. Most of us, of course, see this as a curse, according to Stephanie Foo.
在我们的一生中，有一种巨大的遗忘暗流，把老同学的名字拉进深渊，把我们学过但从没用过的法语，把我们曾经喜爱过但现在忘了情节和演员的电影冲走。根据斯蒂芬妮·福的说法，我们大多数人当然把这看作是一种诅咒。
I have several large, unwieldy boxes stacked in corners of my apartment. I almost never open them. But I've schlepped these boxes through the 12 tiny apartments I've lived in in the past decade. They're full of notebooks, external hard drives, thousands of sheets of paper, photographs, VHS tapes, full of all my memories, starting with journals I wrote when I was five years old.
我的公寓角落里堆着几个又大又笨重的箱子。我几乎从不打开它们。但我把这些箱子搬过了过去十年我住过的12个小公寓。它们里面装满了笔记本、移动硬盘、成千上万张纸、照片、VHS录像带，装满了我的所有记忆，从我五岁时写的日记开始。
The idea that there are whole weeks, even months, of my life that have just disappeared into the abyss of forgetfulness is horrifying to me. If I can't take these memories with me through the rest of my life, then what's the point of even living them in the first place?
那种我生活中整整几周甚至几个月的时间已经消失在遗忘深渊中的想法，让我感到惊恐。如果我不能带着这些记忆度过余生，那么首先活着又有什么意义呢？
To hold onto the past, a couple times a month, I'll sit at my kitchen table, alone in my apartment, and I'll just start recording these long soliloquies about whatever. Here's one actual recording from February 24, 2014, 11 PM.
为了抓住过去，每个月我会几次坐在厨房桌旁，独自在公寓里，开始录制这些关于任何事情的漫长独白。这是一段2014年2月24日晚上11点的实际录音。
--a six-pack of Corona and Pacifica was $11, which I thought was super atrocious. And so I tried to buy, like, whatever, like a four-pack of cans of Corona-- cans. And he was like, oh, that's $9. And I was like, well, I might as well just buy the [BLEEP] six-packs.
——一箱科罗娜和太平洋啤酒是11美元，我觉得这简直太贵了。所以我试着买，随便吧，比如一四罐装的科罗娜——罐装的。然后店员说，哦，那是9美元。然后我说，好吧，我干脆就买那个[哔]六罐装的算了。
Because I'm sure in the year 2030, that memory is going to be helpful. So all this to say that my obsession with my ever-fleeting memories is what made me really excited when I heard about this condition called HSAM. It stands for Highly Superior Autobiographical Memory.
因为我敢肯定在2030年，那个记忆会很有用。所以这一切都说明，我对飞逝记忆的执念，就是为什么当我听到这种叫HSAM的情况时感到非常兴奋的原因。它代表“极优自传体记忆”。
June 10, 2006-- tell me what was the weather like and what day was that?
2006年6月10日——告诉我那天天气怎么样，是什么日子？
So June 10, 2006 was a Saturday. And I remember it was a nice, sunny day because I was outside for a graduation party. I was actually deejaying the party. That was one of my part-time jobs in college.
所以2006年6月10日是周六。我记得那是个晴朗的好日子，因为我在参加一个毕业派对。我实际上是在给那个派对做DJ。那是我大学时期的兼职工作之一。
Joey DeGrandis is one of only about 60 people in the world who have been officially found to have HSAM. And by the way, I checked-- it was a Saturday and, in Chagrin Falls, Ohio, sunny.
乔伊·德格兰迪斯是全球仅有的约60名被正式认定拥有HSAM的人之一。顺便说一句，我查过了——那天确实是周六，在俄亥俄州的查格林福尔斯，晴天。
Joey remembers very specific details from every single day of the last 25 years of his life. I'm sitting across the table from him when I ask him these random questions. He wasn't prepped on any of them. He's not using his phone to look anything up.
乔伊记得过去25年里每一天的每一个具体细节。我问他这些随机问题时，正坐在桌子对面。他事先没有准备任何一个。他没有用手机去查任何东西。
When were the Oscars in 1999?
1999年的奥斯卡是什么时候？
The Oscars in '99 were on Sunday, March 21.
99年的奥斯卡是在3月21日，周日。
Oh, my God!
哦，我的天！
For a little bonus, I think Whoopi Goldberg hosted it that year. I think.
作为一个额外的小奖金，我想那年是乌比·戈德堡主持的。我想是吧。
OK-- which episode is the one where Rachel quits?
好的——哪一集是瑞秋辞职的那一集？
OK. I like the first few seasons of Friends more than the others. So I think that that was season 3. I want to say December 12, '96.
嗯，比起其他几季，我更喜欢《老友记》的前几季。所以我认为是第三季。我想是96年12月12日。
Oh, my God! Yes! That's amazing!
哦，我的天！是的！太神奇了！
People with HSAM don't remember everything in their lives, and their memories can be flawed and biased, just like everyone else's. But they remember a whole hell of a lot more than we do and are particularly good at remembering things they care about.
拥有HSAM的人并不能记住生活中的一切，他们的记忆也可能像其他人一样有缺陷和偏差。但他们记得比我们多得多，而且特别擅长记住他们关心的事情。
People with HSAM who love sports have an encyclopedic knowledge of scores. Joey's really good with TV shows. And he tells me it's kind of like all the memories are available at any given time for him to sort of scroll through.
拥有HSAM的人如果热爱体育，他们拥有百科全书式的比赛比分知识。乔伊非常擅长电视节目。他告诉我，对他来说，这就像所有的记忆都在任何时候都可供他翻阅一样。
For the show Mad Men , Don is pitching, I think, Kodak. And, you know, he's talking about the projector, how it's sort of a carousel of memory. And it's not spot on, how I remember things. But it's pretty damn close.
对于电视剧《广告狂人》，唐在提案，我想是柯达。而且，你知道，他在谈论投影仪，它怎么像是一个记忆的旋转木马。我记忆事物的方式并不完全一样，但已经非常接近了。
A carousel of memory?
记忆的旋转木马？
Yeah. And I think that the words-- I'm trying to recall exactly the voiceover for this teaser. But it was something like, there's a rare occasion when the public can be engaged.
是的。而且我想那些词——我正试图精确回忆这个预告片的旁白。但内容大概是，有一种难得的场合，公众可以被触动。
Hold on. Here's that scene.
等一下。这是那个场景。
There's the rare occasion when the public can be engaged on a level beyond flash.
有一种难得的场合，公众可以被触动，超越了表象。
It's nostalgia.
这是怀旧。
Nostalgia.
怀旧。
Delicate but potent, you know? It takes us to a place where we long to go again.
微妙但有力，你知道吗？它把我们带到一个我们渴望再次去往的地方。
It takes us to a place where we ache to go again.
它把我们带到一个我们渴望再次去往的地方。
You know? And that's exactly how I feel when I think about my memories.
你知道吗？这就是我思考记忆时感受到的。
You want to be there?
你想待在那儿吗？
Sometimes I am there, whether or not I choose to.
有时我确实在那儿，不管我愿不愿意。
You know how Facebook gives you notifications about what you posted a year ago today? Joey DeGrandis plays that game in his head all the time. He texts friends on a regular basis, saying, "hey, you moved to New York three years ago today," or, "hey, six months ago today, we went karaokeing in that little basement bar." His friends tell me they enjoy the updates. It's like having your own personal biographer of your friendship.
你知道Facebook是怎么提醒你一年前今天发了什么的吗？乔伊·德格兰迪斯脑子里一直在玩那个游戏。他会定期给朋友发短信说：“嘿，三年前的今天你搬到了纽约，”或者“嘿，半年前的今天，我们在那个小地下室酒吧唱K。”他的朋友们告诉我，他们喜欢这些更新。这就像拥有了一个专属你们友谊的个人传记作者。
But having HSAM is like constantly scrolling through your Facebook wall, 24/7. And just like any sort of late-night scrolling, it keeps him up at night. When Joey lies down, he just starts remembering too much.
但拥有HSAM就像是24小时全天候地不断滚动你的Facebook动态墙。而且就像深夜刷手机一样，这让他晚上无法入睡。当乔伊躺下时，他就是开始记起太多东西。
Lately, he thinks over and over about a guy he dated, which seems normal, except their whole relationship only lasted for a couple of months. And it ended two years ago. But Joey can't help but go through their whole relationship in incredibly minute detail on a regular basis.
最近，他反反复复想着他约会过的一个男人，这看起来很正常，除了他们整段关系只持续了几个月。而且两年前就结束了。但乔伊忍不住定期、极其详细地重温他们整段关系。
March 19, 2014. We went to Max Brenner in Union Square and had sundaes and chocolate. And, oh, it was so fun and romantic! You know? Like, that was--
2014年3月19日。我们去了联合广场的Max Brenner吃了圣代和巧克力。哦，太有趣、太浪漫了！你知道吗？就像，那是——
March 20-- and he's like, oh, my God, Joey! You're, like, the funniest person I know. And, of course, my heart grew three sizes.
3月20日——他说，哦，天哪，乔伊！你是我认识的最有趣的人。当然，我的心胀大了三倍。
Oh, my God.
哦，天哪。
Because I'm like, oh, this must be it!
因为我在想，哦，这一定就是了！
The next day, he texted me a picture of his cat, and it was--
第二天，他给我发了一张他猫的照片，那是——
March 29, so that next week, was the first time that we had a sexual encounter. And that was really exciting for me because, again, this was just, like, more confirmation of the fact that maybe this is something. Maybe this is--
3月29日，也就是下周，是我们第一次发生性关系。这对我来说真的很令人兴奋，因为，再一次，这就像，是对那个事实的更多确认，也许这是真的。也许这是——
April 19, which was Easter weekend, 2014, everything just kind of went downhill. And so then it all fell apart, you know?
4月19日，那是2014年的复活节周末，一切都走下坡路了。然后一切都崩溃了，你知道吗？
That's the problem. How do you get over someone when you can't forget them?
这就是问题所在。当你无法忘记某人时，你怎么能走出来？
Well, the way I explain it is you know how you've got your baggage? I got a steamer trunk.
嗯，我解释的方式是，你知道你有的那些包袱吗？我有一个大行李箱。
Jill Price also has HSAM. She just turned 50 and says she's got 50 years of stuff, and the steamer trunk is humongous. Or, shifting metaphors a little--
吉尔·普莱斯也有HSAM。她刚满50岁，说她有50年的东西，那个大行李箱巨大无比。或者，稍微转换一下隐喻——
So if you were-- you know, you have, like, every day is like a bag of garbage. And then you go to sleep, and you wake up the next day. And it's a fresh day. And you can throw that garbage bag out from the day before. I don't have that. I got massive amounts of just piled up garbage bags everywhere.
所以如果你是——你知道，你有，每一天就像一袋垃圾。然后你睡觉，第二天醒来。那是崭新的一天。你可以把前一天的垃圾袋扔掉。我没有。我到处都是堆积如山的垃圾袋。
Jill lives in LA, and she's worked as a script supervisor. On set, her HSAM was really useful because her job was to make sure that continuity was preserved throughout the film-- that someone's hair looks the same from shot to shot, that a table is set in exactly the same way. And of course, Jill remembered how that table looked, even if the last shot happened weeks ago.
吉尔住在洛杉矶，她曾担任剧本监督。在片场，她的HSAM非常有用，因为她的工作是确保整个拍摄过程中的连续性——发型在不同镜头之间看起来一样，桌子的布置完全一样。当然，吉尔记得那张桌子是什么样，即使最后的拍摄发生在几周前。
I called her up because I wanted to find out if resentment about the past is a side effect of HSAM for anyone other than Joey. Short answer-- yes.
我给她打电话是因为我想查明，对于除了乔伊之外的任何人来说，对过去的怨恨是否是HSAM的一种副作用。简短的回答——是的。
Like, I'm still pissed about stuff from when I was five. And that's ridiculous.
就像，我还在为五岁时发生的事生气。那太荒谬了。
Jill says she can forgive, but she can never forget. But maybe not being able to forget sort of hinders her ability to forgive as well as the rest of us. Like, she told me she's still angry about this thing that happened in her first year at college, three decades ago. Jill had this calendar that she'd used as a diary, writing down details about each of her days in cramped handwriting, so minuscule it's barely legible.
吉尔说她可以宽恕，但她永远无法忘记。但也许无法忘记在某种程度上也阻碍了她像我们其他人一样宽恕的能力。比如，她告诉我她还在为30年前大学一年级时发生的事生气。吉尔曾经有一个日历，她把它当作日记用，把每天的细节写在上面，字体极其细小，几乎难以辨认。
Like written all over. I mean, everything was on there. 1983 was a really important year. Everything was on there, everything you can imagine-- could be the weather. Could be--
就像写满了。我的意思是，什么都在上面。1983年是极其重要的一年。什么都在上面，你能想象到的每一件事——可以是天气。可以是——
Like what do you mean? Like snacks? Like who you talked to? Like, what is everything?
你什么意思？比如零食？比如你和谁谈话？什么是“每一件事”？
Everything! Yes. Everything.
每一件事！是的。每一件事。
Jill left the calendar at her mom's house for a few months while she went back to school, and the next time she came back, the calendar was gone.
吉尔去上学时把那个日历留在她妈妈家几个月，等她下次回来时，日历不见了。
I can't find the calendar. I'm looking everywhere. So I hysterically go running through the house, trying to get my parents to understand what just happened, how important this was. Like, where's my journal? And they're like, well, we don't know.
我找不到日历了。我到处都在找。所以我歇斯底里地在屋子里跑，想让我父母理解刚才发生了什么，这东西有多重要。比如，我的日记哪去了？他们说，嗯，我们不知道。
And I remember they had somebody at the house they were talking to. So it was like I was interrupting some sort of a business meeting. But I was also freaking out, and I didn't really care. And even to this day, just recently, I said to my mom-- you know, I brought that up. I said, and you did not-- you really had no idea.
我记得那时他们家里正有人在谈话。所以我像是打断了某种商务会议。但我当时也在发疯，我根本不在乎。直到今天，就在最近，我还对我妈说——你知道，我提起了那件事。我说，你当时真的一点都不知道。
She thought I was rehashing things. Like, why can't you just get over what happened when you were five? What is this? So she couldn't understand why I was bothered or so upset about things that happened decades ago. Where to me, it was like yesterday.
她以为我是在翻旧账。比如，你为什么不能放下五岁时发生的事？这是怎么回事？所以她无法理解为什么我会为了几十年前发生的事感到苦恼或难过。但在我看来，那就像昨天发生的一样。
Why is it, like, super tragic that you don't have that calendar now?
为什么现在没有那个日历是一件超级悲剧的事？
Well, I do have it because I then went back a couple years later and I rewrote the whole thing. I mean, I couldn't write every single thing. But I tried to go back and redo the entire calendar.
嗯，我确实有它，因为几年后我回去重写了整个日记。我是说，我不可能写下每一件事。但我试着回去重做了整个日历。
Oh, my God.
哦，我的天。
That was how important it was to me. Yeah.
那对我来说有多重要。是的。
And if it's all in your head-- it's saved in there, anyway-- then why bother writing it down?
如果这一切都在你脑子里——反正它已经存进去了——那为什么还要费劲写下来？
Because if I didn't write it down, I would have, like, 50 years of stuff just constantly swirling. And writing it down just sort of relaxes it. And it makes it so that it's there. It's happened. And it's put away. Does that make sense?
因为如果我不写下来，我就会有50年的东西在脑子里不断翻腾。写下来会让它们放松。这让它们在那里。事情已经发生了。而且被收起来了。这说得通吗？
Yeah. It makes a lot of sense.
是的。说得非常通。
I talked to a number of people with HSAM, and it seems like their days are filled with random memories showing up, like bees buzzing around their head, until they can get swarmed. By writing the stuff down, Jill manages the memories, like she's taking them one by one, cataloging them, and putting them into a filing cabinet. There's a link between obsessive-compulsive disorder, OCD, and HSAM.
我和几个拥有HSAM的人谈过，看起来他们的日子里充满了随机出现的记忆，像蜜蜂在脑子里嗡嗡作响，直到被蜂拥。通过把东西写下来，吉尔管理了记忆，就像她把它们一个一个拿出来，归档，放进档案柜一样。强迫症（OCD）和HSAM之间存在关联。
Maybe having the power to remember so much makes you want to obsessively do it all the time. Or maybe it's the other way around-- desperately wanting to remember everything gives certain people the ability to do it phenomenally well. Either way, researchers say, they seem to go hand in hand.
也许拥有如此强大的记忆力会让你想要强迫性地随时做这件事。或者反之亦然——极度想要记住每一件事给了某些人非凡的记忆力。无论哪种情况，研究人员说，它们似乎是相辅相成的。
About a year and a half ago, I had a really bad break up. And one of the ways I got over my ex was by managing my memories, which is a pretentious way to say I told myself he was a douchebag. I dwelled on all the bad parts of the relationship, all his irritating qualities. But recently, I was flipping through some entries in my journal from a few months before it got bad-- not for fun, for this story. I'm not that far gone.
大约一年半前，我经历了一次非常糟糕的分手。我走出前任阴影的方法之一就是管理我的记忆，这是一种自命不凡的说法，意思是我告诉自己他是个混蛋。我沉溺于这段关系的所有糟糕部分，他所有令人恼火的品质。但最近，我在翻看分手前几个月写的日记——不是为了好玩，是为了这个故事。我还没走那么远。
In one entry, he intuited when I was feeling low and said exactly the right thing. In another, we went to a perfect dinner where we got free dessert. Restaurants were constantly giving us free food. We couldn't figure out why, but eventually settled on the idea that people liked us because we just looked so happy.
在其中一篇日记里，他直觉到我感到低落，说了完全正确的话。在另一篇里，我们去吃了一顿完美的晚餐，还得了免费甜点。餐馆一直给我们免费食物。我们搞不清为什么，但最终归结于人们喜欢我们，因为我们看起来太快乐了。
I had, of course, blocked all of these memories out because they didn't fit into the story I was telling myself. And I did not want them back. It had been good to forget. And the difference between me and people with HSAM is that I have the choice to stop reading the diary, to just walk away. Jill doesn't have that choice.
我当然已经屏蔽了所有这些记忆，因为它们不符合我告诉自己的那个故事。我不想把它们找回来。忘记本身是件好事。而我和拥有HSAM的人的区别在于，我有选择不再读日记、直接走开的权利。吉尔没有那种选择。
It didn't paralyze me until my husband died. Like, his death has really, like, paralyzed me.
直到我丈夫去世前，它都没有让我瘫痪。他的死真的让我瘫痪了。
How is it paralyzing?
是怎么瘫痪的？
Because I will never, ever, ever, ever forget that.
因为我永远、永远、永远、永远不会忘记那件事。
Of course, no one forgets their spouse dying. But for Jill, it's different.
当然，没人会忘记配偶去世。但对吉尔来说，那不同。
I am still in March of 2005.
我依然待在2005年的三月里。
When he died?
他去世的时候？
Yeah. Not every minute, but I could really put myself in that week and feel it and--
是的。不是每分钟，但我真的能把自己放回到那个星期，感受它，而且——
So it hurts like it happened yesterday?
所以它伤得就像昨天发生的一样？
Yeah. Now, the feeling that I was not going to survive, I don't feel that way anymore because I have survived, you know? But--
是的。那种我以为自己活不下去的感觉，我现在不再那么觉得了，因为我已经活下来了，你知道吗？但是——
How often do you think about that?
你多久会想一次那件事？
Probably like 10 times a day. Even though I get up every day, I feel like I'm still standing in the same place. It's like-- it's really being stuck. It's being stuck in a moment that you can't-- there's no escaping it.
大概一天10次吧。即使我每天都起床，我觉得自己依然站在同一个地方。就像——这真的是卡住了。这是被卡在了一个你无法——根本没法逃脱的瞬间。
Do you wish that you could forget it?
你希望你能忘记它吗？
Yeah. Or remember it the way normal people remember it.
是的。或者像正常人记得它那样去记得它。
How do normal people remember it?
正常人是怎么记得它的？
I don't know. But it's not, like-- I mean, I don't think that somebody would be sitting here 11 years later still feeling it the way I feel it. See I wish you could understand, and I wish I could understand what it's like to be able to, like, let things fade and-- or not let, just that's the way it is.
我不知道。但它不是，像——我是说，我不认为有人会在这里11年后依然以我感受它的方式去感受它。看，我希望你能理解，我希望我能理解那种让事情褪色是什么感觉，或者不是让它褪色，只是事物本该如此。
Jill says it's not like she's only reliving bad memories. She likes to go back to one of her favorite afternoons-- October 19, 1979, in the ninth grade, when she had a bad day at school, and her mom surprised her with homemade soup when she got home. But when the bad ones come on, she can't help but get emotional. And they come on all the time.
吉尔说，并不是说她只在重温糟糕的记忆。她喜欢回到她最喜欢的下午之一——1979年10月19日，九年级时，那天她在学校过得很糟，回家时妈妈给了她自制的汤作为惊喜。但当坏记忆来袭时，她忍不住变得情绪化。而且它们随时都会来。
If you did not have HSAM, how do you think your life would be different today?
如果你没有HSAM，你觉得你的生活今天会有什么不同？
I think that I would have been able to move forward. I think I probably would be married today. I don't think I would be so scared. I would be able to just walk forward instead of constantly looking back. OK. So let's reverse this so that maybe you understand. So your boyfriend-- you guys broke up.
我想我本来能够继续前行。我想我今天可能已经结婚了。我不认为我会这么害怕。我本来能够直接向前走，而不是不断向后看。好吧，让我们反过来看看，这样也许你能理解。所以你的男朋友——你们分手了。
Yeah.
是的。
How long were you, like, upset about it or until the point where you felt like you can move forward without thinking about it all the time or move forward without it, like, ripping your heart out?
你难过了多久，或者说直到什么时候你觉得你可以继续前行，而不用一直想着它，或者不用再因为它心碎？
Oh, God. Like, three months?
哦，天哪。三个月吧？
[LAUGHTER]. I don't have that luxury.
[笑声]。我没有那种奢侈。
And so are you jealous of me?
所以你嫉妒我吗？
No.
没有。
No?
没有？
Nuh-uh. Because on the flip side of all that, I can't imagine what it's like to not remember my life. I really can't understand how nobody does, even though it has tormented me. It's just, everything was just-- is so important to me that I just-- I hold onto it so tight that I wouldn't want to not be able to do that.
没有。因为从另一方面来看，我无法想象忘记我的生活是什么样子。我真的无法理解怎么会有人做到这一点，尽管它折磨了我。就是，每一件事都那么重要，以至于我——我紧紧抓住它，我不想让自己失去这种能力。
I'm not jealous of her, either. Ever since talking to these people with HSAM, for the first time in my life, I actually feel just fine about forgetting. I know that sounds like it's the end of the radio story and this is just what you say, but, like, I cannot stress how sincere I am about this-- totally fine about forgetting.
我也不嫉妒她。自从和这些拥有HSAM的人交谈后，我一生中第一次，对于遗忘感觉相当好。我知道这听起来像是电台故事的结尾，而且这只是你应该说的话，但是，我无法强调我是多么真诚——对于遗忘，我感觉完全没问题。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program.
斯蒂芬妮·福是我们节目的制作人之一。
Well, our program was produced today by Sean Cole, Zoe Chace, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Joel Lovell, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Lyra Smith, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Help from Julie Snyder and Elna Baker. Support staff for our show-- Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, and Seth Lind. Research help from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Music help today from Damian Graef, from Rob Geddis.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由肖恩·科尔、佐伊·蔡斯、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·福、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、乔尔·洛弗尔、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、莱拉·史密斯、阿丽莎·希普、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克制作的。感谢朱莉·斯奈德和埃尔纳·贝克的帮助。我们节目的支持人员——埃莉斯·伯格森、艾米丽·康登、金伯利·亨德森和塞思·林德。克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和米歇尔·哈里斯提供了研究帮助。今天的音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫，来自罗布·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I always tell him, every day is a bowl of cherries. And he always responds--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心PRX送达公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我总是告诉他，每一天都是一碗樱桃。他总是回答——
Every day is like a bag of garbage.
每一天都像一袋垃圾。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。